thanks for being with us America this is
the Dave Ramsey show Kim is with us in
Yorktown in Virginia I cam how are you
I'm good Dave how are you better than I
deserve what's up well thank you so much
for taking our call I've got a question
my husband and I we have a mortgage on
our current home we also have a mortgage
on a rental home that we cannot sell
because of family dynamics and grandma
gave us the land to build on that were
kind of stuck with it right now
my husband makes the land around the
family dynamics grandma owns the land
she gave us two acres to build on under
the condition you ever sell it sort of
if we were to sell it it would divide
the land so there would be no access to
half of it okay who owns the land around
it now grandma gramma still owns it yes
and she's 98 so and how much is a
homeless and rental property we owe
about 75 thousand nitori's immortal
parts worth one it's probably worth
thirty thousand it's in rural Michigan
so there's no kind of market we've tried
renting it out so your son yeah so for
right now we're just trying to get get
rid of the mortgage on it and pay it off
we pay for years of been paying you know
just an extra $25 a month
oh yeah it's horrible
when we started wearing baby step two
when we started my husband was making
125 thousand and unfortunately we were
the typical trying out earn our
stupidity like you name it we did it we
had payday loans and all the stupid
things you could do and we started we
were at negative $1400 a month with his
raise and with go following the baby
steps and working odd jobs and selling
everything in the house we're now
thankfully to the point where you know
we're clearing we've so far we've
cleared right around $45,000 of our debt
we have 80,000 remaining including this
on this bad deal no I'm shooting it my
question was do we add the rental now
that the rental home mortgage is less
than half of our annual income do we add
that to our debt snowball because
that'll add a year basically to maybe
step two well it doesn't matter to me
you're gonna have to clean this mess up
one time or another so at some point
you're going to lose forty or fifty
thousand dollars on this piece of
property right yes okay and so you built
a house I want it to live and then you
moved is that what happened yes my
husband was working for his parents
business and the business went under so
we couldn't stay in the area so then we
moved to Virginia so Ronnie went when
granny dies what happens to the land I
think when granny dies that we will be
able to land goes to my husband's father
who also has moved away from the area so
I think at that point we will be able to
sell okay so okay so you're just trying
to hold on for a little while I'm gonna
put out a baby step six cuz you're gonna
ride it you're not to write check cuz
you're upside down either way but it's
just a matter of how much you're going
to lose here right exactly and we
hopefully hopefully your father-in-law
will sell the land and you can package
this with it and the buyer will want it
all is what I'm saying
that that's what we're hoping I mean
it's a dairy farm across the street and
if they want to expand it would be ideal
but I don't know that that will happen
yeah well if they don't someone else is
going to own a farm in their area
because the father-in-law is probably
not going to keep that he's already lost
a business yes and he has moved to
Florida and he never wants to go back so
I feel fairly confident that when
Grandma is gone that it won't be a
problem we've just been paying on it we
built it I would go ahead I would go and
have a discussion with father-in-law
given that he's the sole heir and let's
go ahead and start talking about this at
Thanksgiving not like I'm planning
granny's death or anything but just we
got to have a game plan but put it at
baby step six because you're just going
to lay this
as you can and then your you know when
you get around to paying it off
hopefully all you'll have to pay off is
the deficit you won't have to pay off
the whole thing okay yeah and let's just
push it out to baby step six
okay I appreciate that can I ask you one
more brief question in August of this
year we had about five thousand dollars
worth of emergency between the rental
house we had bad tenants that trashed it
and that was about well I guess it was
more than that it was $7,500 in rental
repairs that we had to do and then we
had a flood in my current home where we
live so it's a little bit more we cash
flowed everything thankfully would it be
appropriate then to adjust our emergency
fund to two thousand dollars versus the
one thousand doesn't matter
wouldn't helped you anyway that's true
Justin it's just a matter of you're
looking for a comforts you're not gonna
have until you're out of debt and have
your emergency fund in place and so
you're not gonna feel that that sense of
relief that you're looking for until you
get there mm not gonna do it for you I
mean it's a fall if it gives you comfort
it's a false comfort it shouldn't have
because mathematically you've already
had 12/5 that your cash flowed and you
know you can do that so I don't think it
matters I'm going to keep it at a
thousand and keep pushing that through
hey thanks for calling in we appreciate
your joining us I think this is probably
the I'm gonna make up a number the tenth
time in the last ten years that I've had
that call or something pretty similar so
let me outline that because it almost
never happens but it happens often
enough that and it's so sad when it does
if your family wants to give you the
corner of their farm to build on don't
take it let me say it again if your
family wants to give you the corner of
their farm to build on don't take it
because you can never sell it because
everybody's gonna be pissed off that you
took the house and sold it you took a
piece of the farm and sold it you took a
little bit of the farm and sold it and
the you know daddy's gonna be mad
Mama's gonna be mad grandma's gonna be
mad Uncle Bob's gonna be mad that you
sold off part of the family farm after
after your grandmother gave you that
land you sold it when they give it to
you there are strings attached and their
emotional strings there's not a legal
debt are not a legal liens on the deed
no deed restrictions most of time but
there's this unwritten thing that when
you sell it everybody in the family's
pissed off and so you were just given a
piece of ground you can't get rid of
forever it's not a gift it's a problem
it's not a blessing it's a curse and
then you go build a dadgum house on it
and put a mortgage on it now you're
really screwed and that's exactly what
happened to her and I have taken this
call so many times I remember one of
them we actually made a promo out of it
because the lady's like well my
father-in-law said we can't sell it and
I said well it is a deed in your name
yeah well I guess you can put a sign in
the yard now you don't have to argue
with him later he may not want you at
Thanksgiving dinner but he doesn't
really get to tell you what to do
anymore because the deeds in your name
and you got the breakdown of the
relationship at that point but you know
the tails wagging the dog unless he's
gonna start paying your freakin payments
he doesn't get to make your decisions
now Kim's got a 98 year old and so we're
gonna bet the odds here and not try to
play hardball but if grandma was 65 I'd
be advising Kim to make grandma mad
right now because it's 70,000 bucks
worth that crap that that woman's trying
to swim out of that her family got her
into or her husband's family got her
into and here's the sad thing yes
everybody thought they were doing her a
favor
they thought they were dumb helping him
out I'm giving him some land giving him
a little piece of the family here only
you can't ever sell it and let me just
tell you there's nothing is forever even
real estate real estates not forever
nothing is forever Jesus that's all
that's forever everything else comes and
everything else goes and you can bet
your bottom that that dadgum life of
yours is going to change in some way
another and you're gonna want to sell at
some point the number of times someone
in their 20s or 30s builds a house and
stays in that house their entire life is
almost zero so if your family wants to
give you the corner of the farm to build
on just smile and say goodness thank you
so much no no it's a trap it's a trap
they didn't mean for it to be a trap but
it's a trap this is the Dave Ramsey show
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show